tragedia en el Cuscatlán en San Salvador
capital salvadoreña al menos una decena
de personas perdieron la vida resultado
de una estampida humana dentro del
estadio Cuscatlán se jugaba el partido
de vuelta de cuartos de final entre
Alianza y el club deportivo faz cuando
cientos de personas saltaron de las
gradas al campo escapando de la asfixia
provocada por la multitud de la sección
general de la tribuna hubo una
avalancha lastimosamente habían niños
ancianos ellos fueron los perjudicados y
Ops y gente que
se le ha dado primeros auxilios y
los mayores responsables ahorita son la
autoridad las autoridades del país
centroamericano atribuyen el suceso a la
falta de organización y a la sobreventa
de boletos también es repudiable que las
personas encargadas de estos escenarios
de las ventas de boletos no tengan el
control estricto
aficionados han demostrado que les
vendieron boletos falsos
y les permitieron la entrada otros
hablan de que según de que hubo
sobreventa en el mercado negro y como
haya sido el caso el punto es de que
terminó en una tragedia el presidente
del Salvador nayib bukele se pronunció a
través de su perfil de Twitter
remarcando que su gobierno inició Las
investigaciones y que los culpables de
la tragedia no quedarían impunes la
federación de fútbol salvadoreña lamentó
los sucesos y anunció la suspensión del
torneo nacional